[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
SVD and how you can use it to decompose
high dimensional data matrices X and
this is the Python demo of the
eigenfaces use of the SVD so this is one
of my favorite examples if X is a matrix
which is a library of images of human
faces so each column is a human face
like a picture of a person's face that's
been reshaped into a tall skinny vector
and so I have a bunch of these columns a
bunch of images of people then you can
use the SVD or more precisely than mean
centered SVD that the principal
component analysis of that data to find
a new representation for human faces
that we call the eigen face
representation okay so we're gonna walk
you through that here all of this code
and the data can be downloaded at
databook UW comm this is based on the
Yale faces B data set there was
collected this is a very very
interesting data set so they had a
geodesic dome and a person could sit in
the middle and in this geodesic dome
there were a bunch of lights that would
flash at different angles and cause
different shadows to be cast on the
person's face and in a two second
interval 64 different lighting
configurations would flash and 64 images
of that person would be taken and so
those 64 images are 64 columns in this X
matrix and we have those 64 images for
38 individual people so this is truly a
massive data set I believe each image
has resolution of about 32,000
and there are something like 2400 of
those images so it's a really really big
X matrix and we're gonna factor it using
the SVD okay you can download this data
all faces dot matte it's in a zip file
on this website so we're going to load
it we're gonna figure out what the size
of it is and in this video I'm just
gonna show you what the data looks like
and in the next video we're going to
compute the SVD and start interpreting
these eigen faces okay
so here I'm just gonna create I'm gonna
show you the first 36 people their faces
tiled in a 6x6 array okay so that's what
this is here this all persons is a big
array of images okay and so if I run
that this is what you find these are the
36 people and the first 36 people in
this eigen faces database okay and so
we're going to use these 36 people in
this X matrix to build a lion face basis
an orthogonal basis that you can
represent all human faces in and
remember I told you there are actually
38 faces we're gonna hold out two of
those people and we're gonna see how
good the basis that is derived from
these 36 people how good that basis is
in predicting those those next two
people okay good
so these are all of the individuals and
remember for each individual we actually
have 64 pictures at different lighting
conditions okay so again here I'm just
gonna show you the data I'm gonna make
an 8 by 8 composite for each individual
person all of their different lighting
conditions and all of that data is gonna
go into this big X matrix there each of
these are going to be reshaped into tall
skinny vectors that are gonna be the
columns of X and so if I run this you
find essentially and I let me see if I
can go down good these are the 64 images
for person 1 you can see that there's
all of these different images where
they're go from kind of full lighting to
almost full shadow to half shadow and so
on and so forth and we actually have
these for all of the people for every
single one of those 36 people we have
this massive massive massive library of
all of these different shadow conditions
and that's what's going to go into this
matrix X that's what we're gonna use to
compute our eigenfaces decomposition
okay so that's coming up next
thank you